it's a disaster and it's hard to believe
as you watch that tape that not so long
ago this country actually enforced its
immigration laws not long ago at all in
fact just two years ago in august of
2019 federal agents kicked down the
doors of seven separate chicken plants
in central mississippi they arrested
hundreds of foreign nationals who were
living and working there in violation of
american law several executives of the
poultry plant were later indicted among
the charges brought child labor
so our decadent corporate press
essentially ignored this except to
portray the raids as heartless and
barbaric not surprisingly a trade group
called the national chicken council
agreed with that characterization how
dare the government enforce its own laws
what's interesting is that people who
actually live in central mississippi had
a very different view of what happened
they'd spent years watching helplessly
as foreign workers lowered the wages for
people who were actually born there they
understood immigration as most wage
earners do understand immigration
primarily as an economic question when
you flood the labor pool wages go down
that's called supply and demand
once the illegal workers were gone those
chicken plants were forced to hire
american citizens in this case many of
them were african-american so you'd
think maybe the bite administration with
its much repeated commitment to equity
would think this is good but of course
they didn't care that i'm interested in
helping working-class people of any
color diversity consultants princeton
professors msnbc contributors
transhumanist tech billionaires of
course those are their people that's
their main constituency but blue collar
high school graduates who just want a
decent hourly job no no chance not
interested
so the administration promptly shut down
all workplace immigration rates
now employers who hire illegal aliens in
order to undercut american wages have
the full protection of the department of
homeland security because it's not a
corporate conspiracy or anything don't
you worry
now the rest of the world is fully aware
of this they follow these developments
they have the internet too
as a result as you just heard bill
malugen say a massive migrant caravan
has formed in southeastern mexico in the
city of tapachula we want to show even
more footage of that which you did not
see in bill's report you can see the
caravan is heading here and smashing
through police barricades as it does
[Applause]
[Applause]
everybody sympathizes with migrants who
want a better life in this country of
course our government's primary concern
always must be the welfare of american
citizens in a country that's rapidly
getting poorer which we are
but in general you sympathize but
migrants who
violently break through a police line no
not allowed here ever there's no
possible way the u.s benefits from
anyone who would do that period
and by the way in contrast to previous
years these migrants are not coming
exclusively from latin america they're
coming from as far away as china
and again why wouldn't they come the
border is now open for everyone it's not
just central americans fox's jeff
jenkins has been covering these caravans
for years and this weekend he went to
southwest mexico and immediately saw
something very different watch
we're in the town of weiweitan 16 miles
north of tapachula where this caravan
started you can see them some children
playing on a swing set but we're seeing
a lot of families a lot of children out
here and we're seeing migrants from many
different countries not just central
america which was what was the situation
in 2019 the northern triangle of
honduras guatemala el salvador but we
see haitians in here we even met one
woman from china that we couldn't speak
to her because she didn't speak spanish
or english every migrant we talked to
today said they've got one destination
in mind and that's the united states
so why are they coming we don't need to
guess about that ask the people who are
coming here illegal they're not
embarrassed to articulate it at all
they're coming because they know
immigration enforcement under joe biden
has been suspended in the united states
the white house hasn't simply ended
workplace raids they've also stopped
turning people away at the border so
people just come in and they know
they'll never be forced to leave
already the administration has released
more than 160 000 illegal migrants into
the country with no supervision
whatsoever without telling the people
into whose neighborhoods they're moving
because they don't care what american
citizens think by the way how many are
vaccinated
you can't go to events you can't have a
job in this country without being
vaccinated but if you come here
illegally no problem what does that tell
you now tens of thousands of those
migrants according to documents attained
by fox news have already received work
permits right soon they will receive
free benefits and the health care that
joe biden has promised them that's why
they're coming again just ask them and
they'll tell you why now
the best time
because of the administration
because of joe biden
because of joe biden it's really that
simple
at the same time you should know that
biden has ordered the government to
build a wall around his family's
vacation home in delaware and build it
at public expense diversity may be our
strength he often says that but joe
biden doesn't want it anywhere near him
or his family
now the irony of that is almost
difficult to digest was just a year ago
that biden was telling us that walls are
immoral and that's why he would never
build a wall
there will not be another foot of wall
constructed in my administration
except around my vacation house in
delaware
hypocrite but it's more than
hypocritical
it's criminal and not in a rhetorical
sense joe biden is actively and
intentionally breaking federal law even
as he works to protect himself and his
own family from the consequences of
these lunatic policies
presidents have been impeached for less
than that in fact no american president
whoever has been impeached not andrew
johnson not richard nixon not bill
clinton not even donald trump has ever
even been accused of crimes this
flagrant or this serious not even close
according to new court documents between
january 20th and the end of march just
for example the bite administration
refused to take custody of 37 illegal
immigrants in the state of texas many of
these people had additional criminal
records
according to an affidavit from a texas
sheriff the administration refused to
detain even suspects believed to have
committed aggravated sexual assault and
narcotics violations at the height of a
drug epidemic that's killing almost 100
000 americans every year
so it's really clear this is not simply
an incredibly dangerous and destructive
policy that intentionally hurts america
and it is that no it's more though
it's an unequivocal violation of federal
statute it is in other words a crime
it's a crime
section 236c of the immigration and
national
nationality act requires federal agents
to quote detain and hold any alien who
is released from criminal custody if the
alien entered illegally and is removable
on any of the criminal grounds of
admissibility or if the alien entered
legally and is removable on most all of
the criminal deportation grounds
got that in other words for the safety
of american citizens of course in every
country has laws like this the us
government is required to arrest and
hold criminal aliens and deport them
but joe biden has refused to do that he
is breaking the law
right out in the open
so why hasn't he been impeached
not because he has bad character or he's
senile but because he is breaking
federal law
not long ago joe biden would have been
impeached for that
even democrats understood not so long
ago that immigration law is fundamental
to any country watch
there's a number our obligation as
elected officials to keep the american
people safe
and our borders are our first line of
defense one of our
early lines of defense democrats support
also enforcing laws current laws against
those who came here illegally and those
who hire illegal immigrants the only way
that we will stop the flow of illegal
immigration into this country is tell
those who hire them that they no longer
can
that was before the democratic party
decided to wholeheartedly embrace its
role as corporate toadies and before
more significantly they decided it's too
hard to convince the population that our
policies help them because in fact they
don't help them at all
it's much easier to guarantee that we'll
be elected into perpetuity by importing
a whole new population of voters and
that's exactly what they're doing and
they bark like dogs when you say it
because it's true
but that was their position then in fact
it was the democratic party's official
position watch
the democratic position also recognized
you've got 11 million
illegal aliens here
they have to have a way to earn their
way into the deal this is an amnesty
they're required to take 11 years worth
they pay a fine they got to learn to
speak english they got to pass um
testers part yeah i like that i think if
we want the problems of canada right now
keep encouraging people to keep their
foreign language english is going to
unite this country potentially
i can't think of a country
that has two languages as their accepted
languages that is doing all that well
including switzerland and or
canada
well that was a completely different joe
biden in fact sunday we're just going to
spend an hour playing you tape from joe
biden five years ago and you can decide
how he's doing now but that point that a
divided country is united by language
is true
there is no country in the world that
remains united but has different
languages period and that's essential
fact of of life
and everyone just a few years ago
understood that now joe biden and the
party he leads has decided that really
nothing matters including who lives in
the united states
and amazingly some republicans in the
congress appear to agree hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else